[Musik]
[Applaus]
da hat es ein wunderschöner tag gehabt
ein guter und schöner tag für die
ausgezeichneten soldaten hat für die
nominierten sowie insgesamt noch für das
bundesheer weil wir heute wieder gezeigt
haben wir mit dieser veranstaltung im
schloss esterhazy breit aufgestellt das
bundesheer ist von cyber defense über
arbeitsjahr bis hin zu einem feld koch
der über 100.000 steckt würde jetzt
einer 43 jährigen laufbahn auch per hand
angefertigt hat und damit die soldaten
versteckt hat das heißt ja ein schöner
tag der minister
ich glaube wichtig ist auch dass wir
nicht nur an tagen wie diesen der
soldaten die einheit des tages auch
küren und erden sondern dass wir auch
das ganze jahr gegenüber als
kommandanten aber arbeitsbevölkerung
wertschätzung gegenüber unseren soldaten
auftreten barzone partner nicht noch
mehr sind aber wie gesagt gehört mehr
dazu als nur ein tage werden